barbara compro 3 libras de pasta y 12
onzas de queso para preparar macarrones
con queso cuál es el peso total en onzas
de pasta y queso combinados nos dan el
peso de la pasta en libras y el peso de
queso en onzas y queremos saber el peso
total pero todo debe estar en onzas así
que primero vamos a convertir estas tres
libras de pasta en onzas sabemos que una
libra es igual a 16 onzas no nos están
diciendo aquí así que cuántos eran 3
libras 3 libras a cuántas onzas será
equivalente los invito a que pausa en el
vídeo y traten de resolver esto por su
cuenta si tenemos tres veces esta
cantidad de libras pues también
tendremos tres veces esta cantidad de
onzas y una libra es igual a 16 onzas si
tenemos tres veces esta cantidad pues
tendremos 16 por 3 es igual a 48 48
onzas así
estas tres libras de pasta que compró
bárbara pues también son equivalentes a
48 onzas de pasta así que tenemos 48
onzas de pasta y 12 onzas de queso cuál
es el peso total en onzas pues serán 48
onzas de la pasta más 12 onzas del queso
48 más 12 es igual a 60 60 onzas es el
peso total de la pasta y el queso
combinados hagamos otro ejemplo con
otras unidades
nos dicen que david construye un muro de
ladrillos cada ladrillo mide dos tercios
de pie de largo hay 20 ladrillos
alineados de extremo a extremo del muro
cual es la longitud en pulgadas del muro
aquí debemos poner atención a las
unidades nos dan la longitud de cada
ladrillo en pies vamos a dibujarlo tiene
de largo dos tercios de pie cuál será su
longitud en pulgadas
que un pie es igual a 12 pulgadas así
que si pasamos de un pie a dos tercios
de pie pues multiplique por dos tercios
así que si un pie es igual a 12 pulgadas
quiero conocer las pulgadas equivalentes
a dos tercios de pie pues voy a
multiplicar esta cantidad también por
dos tercios de cualquier forma pueden
ver esto como que estamos multiplicando
ambos lados de la igualdad por la misma
cantidad así que dos tercios de pie va a
ser igual a dos tercios por 12 pulgadas
así que escribimos 12 por 2 tercios y
estos son pulgadas esto va a ser igual a
24 entre 3 pulgadas lo que es igual a 8
pulgadas y como nota adicional les
comento que normalmente se encuentran la
abreviatura de pulgadas con las letras y
n
así que si encuentran unidades de
longitud como y n se habrán que son
pulgadas así que cada ladrillo pueden
ver que mide dos tercios de pie
o que mide 8 pulgadas de largo y tenemos
20 ladrillos alineados de extremo a
extremo así que la longitud de este muro
serán 8 pulgadas por cada ladrillo x 20
ladrillos que nos da 8 por 216 así que 8
por 20 serán 160 pulgadas resolvamos
otro problema más y en esta ocación
veremos algo de volumen blanca compra 2
galones de pintura verde ella usa 5
cuartos de pintura en el porche
delantero y puntos 5 cuartos de pintura
en el columpio del porche cuántos
cuartos de pintura le quedaron al final
a blanca aquí nos están dando la
cantidad original en galones pero nos
preguntan cuántos cuartos le quedaron al
final así que vamos a convertir la
cantidad que tenía ella originalmente de
pintura a cuartos nos dicen que un galón
es igual a cuatro cuartos
dos galones van a ser iguales a el doble
de cuartos así que serán ocho cuartos
una forma de pensar en esto es decir
bueno aquí tengo un galón por cuanto
necesito multiplicar esto para tener dos
galones pues lo multiplicó por dos y si
un galón es igual a cuatro cuartos pues
estos cuatro cuartos también los tengo
que multiplicar por dos para tener la
cantidad de cuartos equivalentes a dos
galones así que ella comienza con ocho
cuartos de pintura y ella usa cinco
cuartos de pintura para pintar el porche
delantero así que a esto le restamos
cinco cuartos y también nos dicen que
usó 0.5 cuartos de pintura en el
columpio del porche así que también
restamos puntos cinco cuartos a que será
igual esto bueno tenemos 8 menos 5 es
igual a 33 menos 2.5 es igual a 2.5
cuartos de pintura que le quedan al
final a blanca y con esto respondemos a
nuestra pregunta
en las unidades que nos interesan que en
este caso son cuartos